we're girl row i'm chillin man first
things first while I I gotta give you
props cuz that all the rappers you have
got the illest shoe game bro and you've
blown it all appreciated I'm I yo this
do while lays LeBron game is off the
chain I below so hey how many pairs of
the LeBron tens do you have already
that's what I want to know I'm Wi-Fi
like 45 a [__] cake they just came
about to come out back in like oh wait
Weesa play the first song that I really
ever heard was the the back in the NGO
mo with you a bumpy oh yeah man love at
the Oakland man yeah man and you know
I've been following your career man I
think you got you know classic mix tapes
man mixtape about nothing more about
nothing of course um and it's just dope
as a fan of yours when the first album
came out and it didn't get as much you
know attention as I thought you deserved
it's great to see you finally get like
recognition as like the star that you
know I'm saying that you that you are
man it's just a good look man so
congrats on the last night year to man
man appreciate my were real man as I so
I I want to kind of be a the assessment
I were hard work it gives you some time
in here you know for sure I think like
someone like yourself in like someone
like 2 Chainz you know saying perfect
example I just work hard and just do
what you do and eventually like everyone
come around to it you know yeah that's
what it is man hey so um ambition drop
man has some crazy crazy singles off of
it my favorite joint was the actual like
ambition record with you me can draw
some or are you working on album number
three at this at this point absolutely
absolutely i'm affected arm and first
quarter next year vice away with noble
on one way at a scheduled actually you
know that but uh you know i'm excited
about the new work who you are you
trying to collab with you collab with a
lot of dough partitive mb I mean you you
linked up with everybody from the roots
you know to Waka Flocka you know you're
very versatile artist who you tryin to
get with on this new album this one
actually might not have a many are many
seats it on it you know and I'm doing a
dinner plate in my career so you know
but I mean whoever will be over it is
definitely the proprietors on it for
sure hey so um Saturday man I I've yet
to see you lie
um Saturday you gonna be doing a thing
at the Monster Energy dub show out here
in Phoenix what can the people expect
from a while a show man where we gonna
get oh man I I try to do all the records
i take the support further formulas and
you know i got that energy on stage man
so you know we gonna have a lot of fun
divine been out that I ain't been out
there in a minute um I feel like you
were kind of one of the first artists
that really were a product like what's
happening right now with the blogs and
stuff in the hip-hop game um and and I
know that you like I said you've you've
worked from everybody from the roots and
now you're wrong with MMG was ever a
point in time where like you got any
flack from like your original like
hardcore like you know it's like sunt
done hip-hop fans that you know we're
support you from the job that we started
making like these more commercial
records the music that I'm making now
like but recently in the studio it's
really like reminiscing and like my
mother not like you know like early
projects like us I like I've been
listening to my older stuff recently you
know they're like my super older stuff
like and some of the ideas from back
there not even coming like back to life
oh no on this new work you know Xena I
even got one or two records that i
reworked you know just to be something a
little bit deeper so you know I is
definitely reminiscent of that you know
I've actually been in the studio with
Mark Ronson you know and I reached out
to like just blaze and things of that no
wow just an body like you know more that
sound that's dope man that's I'm excited
and I see I'm because i'm in a fan of
yours for a minute Sasha's exciting to
hear on from a fan's perspective that's
dope man I appreciate a man so but we we
over for the best me know sometimes it's
hard to get like records from certain
people or or give us to do with certain
people but you know I'm gonna don't
place my career now so sometimes it they
get back to you a little now they'll get
back to you right now they get back to
you man that's what's up are you gonna
be dropping I know that you have a track
record with with with releasing
incredible mixtapes are you gonna be
doing any mixtape project before the
album man I can't let the fans down i'm
not saying yes or nothing no i just
can't let this a man that's the sup man
um what's the best part about I'm
rolling with this MMG squad that that
data Ross is assembled thus far all well
apply when we are in the studio we are
just at the same time it's like a week
everybody's pushing each other like more
than they've ever been pushed today by
said that's only successful artist apart
of your [__] artist oh you know
everybody's pushing each other in a
joint fasho fasho that's what's up man
hey so I got I got it I gotta ask you
did you were you at the BT hip hop
awards last weekend at all yeah well I
did the carpet I did the cover but I had
a show like like 50 minutes away like in
Atlanta won over 50 minutes from Atlanta
like a little festival yeah and uh I
left out there we went out there came
back by the time maybe he is maybe like
15 minutes away from from flirtomatic
city i started reading all this stuff
also you heard about everything that
went down heard about it not honey I
know what was too I I know absolutely
just something so fat I know what's
going on cuz it seems like you're kind
of more like you're of course energy to
the death but it seems like you're kind
of more you're not really you know you
know really don't really get wrapped up
in that in those kind of things I think
obviously you gotta see you you know you
were sir Tina Fey no matter what like
you did to the people that you make
money without feed each other family
like you know but at the same time but I
wasn't nowhere near the whole situation
he knows that I wasn't anywhere near
that tone so I really can't call and say
what happened or what you know what what
what is happening what should happen and
all that it's unfortunate to say delete
I just hope something like this might
might like move everybody closer to like
a more peaceful medium I okay look
everyone had their words [__] almost
went down you know let's just make music
everybody get money but your and I'm
saying as I had to ask you about that
cuz you know you're part of the end
result of it oh man no like I said like
that a sign that we sit around and talk
about like how relationships with other
artists with stuff we never really
talked about nobody but ourselves in
amongst ourselves so you know nobody
really knew our deep anything was a hot
dickk nothing is you know so right I'm
I'm assuming it's the Sun is it blown
out of proportion aye sir I'm promote
far hey so I know you are you are uh the
sports connoisseur man you you've held
your own
on a first take was skip in a stephen
stephen a smith and i just saw that you
and stallion you guys are doing the
actual theme song for the for the show
now yeah yeah how did I how did that
come to be ESP and hit you guys up or
what I'm one of the I'm one of the guys
they like men apparently so here's a
about that I have invited me you know
really come from a sports background so
you know it was it was definitely some
know that over the attica trend or how
you love in rg3 out there in DC though
and I'm not complaining at the friend of
mine you know we check up on each other
all the time and I'm glad we got
somebody with a level head and that
crazy sitting here now since you you
like you know you've appeared on ESPNU
you got your opinion on sports and I
know you follow sports we're in Arizona
right now the Cardinals are for know I
know mmm what are you thinking about our
squad right now I like Patrick Peterson
and I like I like you know i got like
Fitzgerald plant corn I got I got a
great team I got a great team that's
what it is man we got to get it in this
weekend my do while a live on the phone
no don't forget about the surf crew oh
yes he see I see I gotta ask you about
the sun's cuz imma imma imma die hard
sons Cardinals fan all day but I'm not
that excited about this year what do you
mean think this with this new young
squad we've assembled the the Beasley in
the Dragic and all these guys you think
we could make some noise catch without
one of my one Malone's the doctor after
buy them from you might think that Mike
Marshall yeah OSU people's yeah he from
reported ERV man oh that's wassup man
you wanted a young letter in order young
legends I gotta bc i was actually I've
been very unhappy with sons graphics
until until we made that when I was like
you know finally we made a pig that I
thought I think there is gonna be like
you gonna be like you gonna be like
another few nice man I see that's good
news to me you got the insides go did I
miss my father almost with me to see
shiny to come out come out with an angle
chart that's what it is ma'am i do while
a i appreciate you calling in but i'ma
see you this weekend man we got to get
it in like i said Doug like just
congrats homie like I've been a fan for
a very long time and uh like I'm just
glad that that you you finally got the
the look that you deserve man it's just
is a beautiful thing thank you I
appreciate it you know
can't wait I can't wait for a new
mixtape man and I can't wait to hear you
know what does one thing that I i we
actually talked about this on the air a
few weeks ago on my underground show how
a lot of people's core fans disowned
them once they blow up but I feel like a
guy like Drake he's still making the
same kind of music he made before when
he was I kind of like the it artist to
like you know on the underground scene
and I feel like a guy like yourself I
feel like you've never change the type
of music you really make people a lot of
times they attend economy them but you
can't if you take a song like um no hay
and whatever there you can also say dig
the my first go go song was like that it
was a club join it wasn't known there
that record yeah yeah you know fair or
are you know but even on pretty girl
like that was a straight-up no fan this
is not much different in that you know
not you so people kind of just interpret
the music the way they want to interpret
it you know and what it is man is it's
like a lot of times artist like yourself
or like these guys who I feel like it
embraced you know first before the
mainstream I think a lot of these these
these these these bloggers these dudes
will be leaving comments on the blogs
and stuff I feel like once you make it
to a certain point they feel like they
kind of own you as an artist like you're
their little secret and then once you
get to a certain point of like start on
the border they weren't appreciated
affirmed exactly man so wildly I
appreciate you brother we're gonna see
you this weekend man Phoenix about to
tear down saturday Monster Energy dub
show tickets to twenty dollars we're
gonna see you man that MMG love in
Phoenix Israel brother absolutely